where are you skipping to Oh scary
places whoa Simo and Finn and Chewie and
the cockpit has been extremely fun and
sweet starts and now we're doing a quick
test with Daisy we're just kind of doing
the finalized look it's been like quite
a long build-up of freaking out
yeah it's nerve-racking I don't really
know how to describe it but I feel more
the expectation of what people want for
the last chapter I do remember my first
week besides food in Abu Dhabi Fatima
it's all the same levels of nervous
actually
so I remember it vividly and the whole
week was like and it was both amazing
and terrifying
I was doing my walk along the desert
taking off my stormtrooper gear girl it
was very hot and everything it was very
big to me Matt I'm just hammering so big
like Ryan everything is huge like I was
fine starts getting used to a whole new
world when Washington came in to
audition obviously I had the wrong
before it was really more of a
technicality read the scene on how
that's wasting time man and it's nice to
be able to realize that chemistry that
we had on that first wreath
[Music]
we made it one day day one
[Music]